I was checking out the david pakman show
subreddit this morning at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT and saw some
interesting posts a bunch of people have
been picking up on this and user guild
Uruk asks does trump watch the David
Pakman show
and again is pointing to this tweet from
Trump from Tuesday night during the New
Hampshire primary where Trump tweeted
boot edge edge is doing pretty well
tonight giving crazy Bernie a run for
his money and many people pointing out
that I have been pronouncing Pete's name
Boot edge edge for a while but a lot of
this came from Pete remember early on
when people weren't sure how to
pronounce Pete's last name he said it's
like the word boot followed by the word
edge twice so I don't think this is
evidence Trump is watching the David
Pakman show although I appreciate the
sentiment I was sort of joking about
that
Brody Mulligan posted a new low Jimmy
from Phillies call on the livestream
last night yeah
Jimmy from Philly called in and it was
he's a furious Trump supporter who has
actually been been separated from his
daughter for alleged physical violence
it's it's a horrible horrible story and
Brody wrote berating homos mocking
Pete's candidacy as nothing more than a
person with supporters voting for him
based only on its sexual orientation
topped off with needless cruelty towards
the transgender community stating what's
next a transsexual for president David
hung up on him eventually and apologized
to the callers and viewers about having
to listen to all of that and then Brody
finishing by saying I wish Pakman would
stop taking his call sometime yeah you
know it was a very ugly call from Jimmy
from Phil from Philly and I did I did
end it prematurely although arguably not
fast enough the you know when when Jimmy
called in and he was always loud and
rambunctious and had an edge to him but
we actually talked about you know his
view why he likes Trump his views on
politics it was an interesting I can't
allow someone to just get on the show
and insult large swaths of people with
pejorative terms and all of that I
didn't feel good about the call and if
if you know that may
for Jimmy from Philly if that's the way
he's gonna do these calls
lastly eath onna 18 posted david the
debate champion with a screenshot from
saturday's Rajoy al i didn't talk about
this on the show really but I was on a
game show on Saturday called Rajoy al
which starts with 12 contestants after
each topic is debated someone has voted
off the island so to speak and I did win
I actually came out victorious we're
going to publish the finale where I
competed against a gentleman going by
the name airsoft fatty that's his name
I'm not that's not pejorative and we are
gonna publish that to the YouTube
channel over the weekend you can check
out the full video on raj with to Jay's
YouTube channel if you want to see it
but a very very enjoyable and
eye-opening experience
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it I want to encourage
everybody in my audience to go subscribe
to a YouTube channel we're partnering
with it's called up flip they release
new videos every week in every video you
meet a different entrepreneur and get an
in-depth look at how their business
works and how they became successful
it's great if you like shows like Shark
Tank if you own your own business or
you're thinking of starting one the up
flip YouTube channel really does offer a
wealth of knowledge and inspiration as
an entrepreneur myself and a business
owner I've really been enjoying hearing
all of the different stories of the
people that they interview but it's
really fascinating content even if you
don't own your own business to go check
out the up flip youtube channel they're
friends of the David Pakman show I'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip YouTube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
you're watching this on youtube i've put
the link right underneath this video